saviez vous que la famille addams
avait-on ménagers à romorantin avec le
papa florian alias le tronçonneurs fou
la maman deborah la religieuse maléfique
et leurs enfants olivia la sorcière
épaules le clown malicieux pour
halloween leur maison est ouverte au
voisinage et surtout aux curieux qui
osent franchir le portail
on s'attendait à trouver des gens plutôt
sympa et en fait voilà où on en est
arrivé je me sens mal sachez qu'elle est
fait j'espère ne pas perdre la tête
difficile en effet de garder toute sa
tête allongée sur cette guillotine de
trois mètres de haut a parmi les autres
curiosités
notre attaque n'empêche 3-1 pilori un
pendu une scène de crime et bien sûr un
cimetière où les âmes torturées repose
presque en paix
magnifique très bien décorée très très
bonne idée pour animer le quartier quoi
j'aime bien parce que ça fait peur et
c'est marrant des voisins conquis il
faut dire que florian déborah et leurs
enfants ont passé toute une semaine à
décorer leur maison
cette passion à nous est venue ni
environ cinq ans à force de regarder des
films d'horreur de voir les maisons
décorées donc dans d'autres pays
sous le thème d'halloween ça nous a
donné envie de recréer ça chez nous
pourquoi cette plaie halloween
parce qu'on a des bon bout vous l'aurez
compris si vous passez du côté de
romorantin d'ici le soir d'halloween
n'oubliez pas d'emmener quelques
gourmandises et votre bonne humeur
ici les voisins sont vraiment charmant
[Applaudissements]